>>Steve: Guys, you ready?
>>Yeah!
>>All right, here we go!
>>Wow, oh, my goodness, whoa!
>>Christian: The first thing
that hit me when we walked
in the room this morning was just
how much light, how much space,
and how alive the room felt.
>>What do you think, guys?
>>Whoo! [clapping and cheering]
>>Melanie: Very bright!
>>Michael: I was just going to
say, it looks brighter already!
I can see the light coming in.
Wow! That's fantastic!
Looks like you've reset
up these tables.
>>Melanie: Yeah, well, you'll notice
that there's a lot more
room to walk around.
And so one of the reasons we set
up the tables this way is just
that flow was a big thing
missing from the classroom,
and it's one of the
most important things
for collaboration and group work.
>>Student: I like the way that
like everything looks kind
of like more organized, and there's
a lot more space in the room,
so it's easier for us to
like walk around the room.
>>Christian: Are you saying your
teacher wasn't as organized before?
[laughter]
>>Student: No, I mean, well, maybe.
>>Michael: That is a
fantastic whiteboard he's got.
>>Melanie: We noticed that when
he went to go set-up his work
that he was losing
a lot of efficiency,
and it was causing some
classroom management issues.
So by making something that is
always ready, he's going to be
so much more efficient and
commanding of his class.
>>Student: We'll be able
to see things better,
because the projector's really big,
and then we still have a
whiteboard right there.
>>Michael: The teaching station,
it feels like it's
been moved back a bit.
>>Melanie: Yes, it has, we wanted
him to be immersed in the class.
Not only does it allow him to see all
of his students, but it allows him
to feel like he has
control over the room,
and kind of mix the materials he
needs to instruct on a daily basis.
We wanted every tool he needed to
be instantly here and not distracted
by other clutter, not
underneath something.
So what we did was we
took this reclaimed desk,
put it on top of this cart.
Painted one side white, so it's
always a whiteboard, and took a piece
of reclaimed Plexiglas,
and screwed it to the top.
>>Michael: He can do the
equations right on here.
>>Melanie: Yeah, and then just erase
like an overhead projector
for the 21st Century.
>>Michael: That's a fantastic idea!
>>Melanie: This whole
wall is whiteboards.
So not only do we have teachable
space at the front of the room,
but we have space that anybody
can use to be a teacher,
or solve a problem in
the back of the room.
One thing that we wanted to play with
was not only providing them monitors
and technology at their height,
so that they could touch down,
but giving them analog tools as well.
>>Michael: Actually do some
thinking on the wall together.
Quickly look something up online,
and then head back to their table.
>>Melanie: Mm-hm.
This action not only did
it liberate this space,
but it created a new opportunity
for their collaboration in the room.
This is a work in progress.
We don't want to give
a teacher a classroom.
we want to create it with them,
so that they continue
to create it over time.
>>Michael: Yeah.
>>Christian: What we hope we've done
over the last week is shift mindsets.
Maybe more importantly, what we hope
we've done is given Steve the set
of tools to be a designer
himself, and to literally imagine
that this space is a studio that
can do anything he needs it to do.
>>Steve: This entire
design project has molded me
into a more empowered teacher.
It's nice to know as a teacher
that we have support coming
from other people, and the kids
coming in on their day off,
and the parents-- and it's nice
to know that there are people
out there looking out for us,
and we don't just feel alone.
>>Narrator: In a single weekend,
one teacher, a few experts,
some community volunteers, and
a bunch of energetic students,
not only transformed their learning
space, they reminded themselves
of the power of their
own imaginations.
What can you do to
remake your classroom?